In this recitation,
we will see how
to apply clustering
techniques to segment images,
with the main application being
geared towards medical image
segmentation.
At the end of this
recitation, you
will get a head start on
how to cluster an MRI brain
image by tissue substances and
locate pathological anatomies.
Image segmentation
is the process
of partitioning digital images
into regions, or segments,
that share the same visual
characteristics, such as color,
intensity, or texture.
The segments should
also be meaningful,
as in they should correspond to
particular surfaces, objects,
or even parts of an object.
Think of having an
image of a water pond,
a mountain chain in the
backdrop, and the sky.
Segmenting this
image should ideally
detect the three
different objects
and assign their
corresponding pixels
to three different regions.
In few words, the goal
of image segmentation
is to modify the representation
of an image from pixel data
into something meaningful
to us and easier to analyze.
Image segmentation has
a wide applicability.
A major practical
application is in the field
of medical imaging, where
image segments often
correspond to different tissues,
organs, pathologies, or tumors.
Image segmentation helps locate
these geometrically complex
objects and measure
their volume.
Another application
is detecting instances
of semantic objects such as
humans, buildings, and others.
The two major domains that
have seen much attention
recently include face
and pedestrian detection.
The main uses of facial
detection, for instance,
include the development of the
auto-focus in digital cameras
and face recognition commonly
used in video surveillance.
Other important applications
are fingerprint and iris
recognition.
For instance,
fingerprint recognition
tries to identify print
patterns, including
aggregate characteristics of
ridges and minutiae points.
In this recitation, we
will look in particular
at the medical
imaging application.
Various methods have been
proposed to segment images.
Clustering methods are
used to group the points
into clusters according to
their characteristic features,
for instance, intensity values.
These clusters are
then mapped back
to the original spatial
domain to produce
a segmentation of the image.
Another technique
is edge detection,
which is based on detecting
discontinuities or boundaries.
For instance, in a
gray-scale image,
a boundary would correspond
to an abrupt change
in the gray level.
Instead of finding boundaries
of regions in the image,
there are other
techniques called region
growing methods,
which start dividing
the image into small regions.
Then, they sequentially
merge these regions together
if they are
sufficiently similar.
In this recitation, our focus
is on clustering methods.
In particular, we will review
hierarchical and k-means
clustering techniques
and how to use them in R.
We will restrict ourselves
to gray-scale images.
Our first example is a
low-resolution flower image
whose pixel
intensity information
is given the data
set flower.csv.
Our second and major example
involves two weighted MRI
images of the brain.
One image corresponds
to a healthy patient,
and the other one corresponds
to a patient with a tumor
called oligodendroglioma.
The pixel intensity
information of these two images
are given in the data sets
healthy and tumor.csv.
The last video will
compare the use, pros,
and cons of all the analytics
tools that we have seen so far.
I hope that this will
help you synthesize all
that you've learned to give
you an edge in the class
competition that
is coming up soon.